bonsoir et bienvenue je suis ravi de
vous retrouver au programme de ça vous
regarde ce soir on va revenir sur le
coup de théâtre de la nuit dernière dans
l'hémicycle sur le pass sanitaire le
gouvernement fait l'expérience de la
faiblesse de son assise parlementaire
toutes les oppositions la nuque le rn
mais aussi les nerfs ont mêlé leurs voix
pour rejeter le retour du pass aux
frontières rapport de force défavorable
ou vrai problème de méthode et si ce
camouflet pour l'exécutif était le début
d'une longue série grand débat dans un
instant sur ce plateau avec nos invités
toute manière des poils nébuleuses
planétaires collision galactique les
premières images du télescope james webb
sont tout simplement magnifiques bijoux
technique c'est le plus puissant le plus
grand observatoire jamais lancé dans
l'espace on en parlera avec le physicien
et philosophe des sciences etienne klein
notre grand témoin ce soir enfin 3 a
franchi ce soir le dersim de brandon
ouaret retour sur les grandes interviews
présidentielles du 14 juillet parler
c'est le mot de la semaine choisi par
notre sémiologue mariette darrigrand et
puis le regard sur le monde isabelle
lasserre quand la milice russe wagner
recrute directement dans les prisons
voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
elle feint quoique un camouflet ou tout
simplement la première traduction
concrète de la nouvelle donne politique
à l'assemblée va-t-il falloir s'y
habituer et mons par marc ferracci et
merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des français établi en
suisse et vous étiez dans l'hémicycle
jusque tard hier soir bonsoir elsa
faucillon soir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau députés communistes des
hauts-de-seine nombre de la nuque vous
vous êtes largement félicitée d'avoir
réussi à mettre le gouvernement en
minorité au vous entendra d'ailleurs
dans quelques instants bonsoir max
brisson soins et mercy est d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes
sénateur les républicains des pyrénées
atlantiques le sénat sur lequel compte
maintenant elisabeth bornes pour
réécrire ce texte pour revenir à la
version initiale on va on va rentrer
dans le détail vous allez nous aider à
comprendre la stratégie dlr qui n'est
pas toujours parfaitement lisible enfin
jean philippe desrosiers et
constitutionnaliste et professeur de
droit public à l'université de lille va
nous rejoindre dans un tout petit
instant mais d'abord que s'est-il passé
hier soir bonsoir stéphane souvent dire
bonsoir à toutes et à tous allez on
plante le décor comme chaque soir avec
vous lègue de blacko pour démarrer
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir alors si
j'ai bien compris myriam on se demande
comment le gouvernement va réussir à
faire adopter son projet de loi son
pouvoir d'achat vu que cette nuit il a
même pas été capable de faire adopter un
texte a priori beaucoup plus simple sur
la fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
alors à vrai dire le projet de loi de
veille sanitaire a quand même a été
adoptée cette nuit alors il a été adopté
mais sans l'article 2 or l'article de
fait l'article central puisque c'est
celui qui aurait autorisé le
gouvernement à rétablir un contrôle
sanitaire aux frontières sachant qu'un
des polémiques c'était que en parlant de
frontières ça inclut aussi la corse et
les rites territoire premiers qui sont
pas vraiment au delà des frontières un
dans l'esprit donc regarder la joie de
l'opposition au moment où effectivement
l'article de été rejetée donc ça c'est
vu des bornes majorité voyez c'est un
peu le dit l extrême gauche de
l'hémicycle à l'extrême droite aussi
donc vous voyez à la majorité ont dit ah
bah voilà
ils applaudissent ensemble et rennes et
les filles voyez bien que c'était ce
qu'on avait dénoncé depuis le début donc
la satisfaction de sébastien chenu un
peu probants peut-être je sais pas vous
allez voir ces modifications
substantielles faut qu effectivement ce
texte en sortie de débats ne ressemble
plus vraiment à grand chose il faut bien
le dire ne ressemble plus en tous les
cas à ce que vous nous aviez proposé et
tant mieux du côté danube est ce si on
était très content vous étiez contente
elle a fait sion mais il ya le côté
nubes toujours un peu révolté toujours à
peu en colère même quand on est content
on vous écoute c'était à la fin du débat
cette chambre d'enregistrement
que vous désiriez cette assemblée de
playmobil qui ne répond qu aux
injonctions de l'exécutif eh bien les
finis elle est finie
nous ne sommes pas là nous ne sommes pas
là pour valider le programme d' emmanuel
macron nous avons même été élu pour s'y
opposer résolument
lorsque vous dîtes pas jusqu'à présent
c'est que les républicains
aussi on va
mais j'avais oublié les républicains
désirent ils sont discrets les
républicains il faut pas trop de bruit
sont pas tellement nombreux mais leur
rôle a été décisif hier soir parce que
si il n'avait pas voté contre cet
article 2 eh ben il aurait été adoptée
absolument sans problème on va regarder
non plus des sorties oui qu'est-ce qui
le revoilà et oui on a envie de savoir
si la comprends je vais dire est ce
qu'on est la raison qui les a poussé à
refuser de voter cet article 2 elle
n'est pas comprise dans l'article 2 est
la même rien à voir avec l'article 2 on
écoute les explications de raphaël
jeunesse hélène berger ah ben voilà je
n'avais pas le dire sipa le point pour
nous qui achoppe dans ce texte
évidemment le silence et l'absence sur
la question de la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés c'est notre
principal regret c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas souhaité vous
donnait jusque là un blanc un blanc
seing sur ce texte et nous n'avons pas
souhaité voter le dispositif qui étaient
contenues dans l'article 2 ne doutons
pas de la sincérité des républicains ils
sont un non certainement attachée au
sort des d'aidés soignants qui n'ont pas
été réintégrés on sent aussi que c'est
quand même que l'avertissement
gouvernement ou à la majorité pour dire
ce message c'est si on n'est pas là pour
vous soutenir tout va être beaucoup plus
compliqué vous pensez que le
gouvernement va céder aux républicains
réintégrer les soignants non vaccinés et
ben non parce que vous savez qui est le
porte parole du gouvernement c'est
l'ancien ministre de la santé alors
contre lui explique réintégrer les non
vaccinés à l'hôpital ça permettrait de
faire mieux fonctionner l'hôpital ou
mieux faire fonctionner et les maisons
de retraite et ben lui c'est pas
tellement son avis en écoute vous posez
la question des ehpad ce sont 100
infirmières qui sont concernés par la
suspension c'est à dire en moyenne une
infirmière pour soixante dix ehpad donc
quand j'entends que les états ne
fonctionne pas bien parce que les
soignants 106 tendu je vous renvoie ces
chiffres qui ont ce côté factuelle qui
est il qui le rend inattaquable donc
vous voyez dans son discours de
politique générale elisabeth bande avait
répété une vingtaine de fois bâtir
ensemble nouvelles réformes en fait
bâtir c'est un bon compromis acentic est
en tout cas plus tellement comment
comment il a réagi la première ministre
alors je sais pas exactement mon peut
pas exclure qu'elle ait un peu mal dormi
un jeu je dis ça à cause de l'heure à
laquelle elle a publié son tweet a donc
à 13h50 à me dire que l'heure est grave
donc j'imagine qu'elle réagissait un peu
aux manifestations de joie de
l'opposition qui fêtait sa victoire
voulait au contraire la digne en
conclure stéphane le texte peut encore
être adopté dans sa version initiale du
lycée n'est que le début on fait du
processus il va passer au sénat puis tu
vas revenir on va parler navette à
l'assemblée aura donc la version
définitive qui sera voté donc il ya
encore beaucoup de travail pour françois
drones pour défendre ce texte donc on a
pensé pour lui parce que veut on sent
que déjà que ça lui pèse mes fins il va
y aller à la seule boussole je les dis
c'est de préserver la santé des français
de tous les français
nous sommes au début du processus
législatif
et inlassablement je continuerai à
essayer de vous convaincre de la
pertinence et de la justesse de
l'article 2 il ya une chose qui est sûre
c'est qu'on ne peut pas lui reprocher
l'arrogance qu'on a reproché à tant
d'autres ministres et attendons
président ça il l'a pas est ce que ça
sera suffisant pour trouver un accord là
il ya débat je voulais c'est bien merci
le décor est planté et dans le détail
merci beaucoup stéphane marc ferracci
comment vous analyser ce qui s'est passé
hier soir après tout leur est si grave
que ça comme dit le premier ministre la
première ministre c'est la démocratie
parlementaire qui s'est exprimé je pense
que si le terme leurs gravats doit être
interprété six à l'aune de la situation
sanitaire et des impacts que va avoir ce
vote sur la capacité que nous avons
collectivement à maîtriser l'épidémie
vous l'avez dit ça a été bien précisé on
se prive avec la le rejet de l'article 2
et bien d'un outil de contrôle aux
frontières à travers le passé ni terre
et non pas le post vaccinales je pense
que la nuance est importante
et cet outil de contrôle manquera
forcément à un moment à un moment où il
ya 130 mille cas aujourd'hui par jour
on y vient on avait alain fischer sur
ces mêmes
jeunes eux d'être on prépare normalement
on sait que on sait que on sait que
l'épidémie est en train de progresser
est toujours en train de progresser que
c'est préoccupant est que dans ce
contexte parce qu'on a maintenant un peu
de recul après des mois et des mois de
gestion de l'épidémie on sait que
certains outils sont utiles et efficaces
et le fait que cet outil est bien pour
vous mettre un veto au retour dépasse
les aggraver la situation sanitaire
vraiment l'escale des pays qui voue
l'exigé tout simplement pour voyager
donc de toutes façons les touristes qui
rompt dans certains pays et beaucoup
devront avoir un pass certes mais
néanmoins de notre point de vue c'est se
priver d'un outil et s'est pas aggravé
la situation sanitaire se priver a pris
cet outil très clair elsa faucillon
quels mots vous mettriez sur ce qui
s'est passé hier soir camouflet victoire
de l'opposition tirer un moment de
clarification
et peut-être une révélation aussi pour
pour la majorité toute relative
renaissance à qui je crois les
oppositions ont permis de révéler et
bien que le parlement allait fonctionner
qu'il fallait faire qu'il allait falloir
s'habituer à ce que nous parlementaires
ont tout simplement que nous jouions
notre rôle est que la démocratie
parlementaire elle doit fonctionner
comme cela dans le fond on sait que nous
ne sommes pas là le banner par exemple
allumer des vrd décision le pass nous ne
sommes pas la chambre d'enregistrement
des décisions du président de la
république c'est comme ça que la
majorité précédente a tenté de faire
fonctionner ce parlement nous disons que
ce n'est plus possible que le paysage
politique et celui de l'assemblée
nationale a changé et nous n'accepterons
pas de continuer à valider cette cette
monarchie présidentielle et 7 cette
assemblée comme chambre d'enregistrement
ensuite je vais aller à la réalité elle
est arithmétique dans l'hémicycle
monarchie présidentielle le fait est
qu'elle n'a pas la majorité absolue donc
on n'est pas là dedans on le voit on le
découvre pas voir dans le texte que les
députés renaissance on n'avait pas vu
cela jusque là et qui hier soir ils s'en
sont certainement peut-être rendu compte
donc c'est pour ça que je dis moment de
révélation et moment de clarification
puisque dès le début du texte nous avons
dit que nous avions des propositions à
débattre notamment sur la question des
tests gratuits sur la question d'un
grand plan pour l'hôpital sur diverses
mesures aussi pour une rentrée scolaire
avec des protocoles clairs au gosier à
noyen opposition avéré loire ma question
est simple est-ce que vous êtes vraiment
opposé au retour sur le fond du pass
fans terre aux frontières en cas
d'urgence puisque en fait c'est même pas
maintenant achevé le ticket de retour à
vannes n'est pas tout à fait ça c'est
important de le préciser quand même à
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent c'est à
dire qu'on reste dans une logique où le
parlement n'est pas celui qui décide le
parlement décide de déléguer les
pouvoirs à la première ministre et au
ministre de la santé c'était sale
article de fumeur de brive reste sur une
logique qui est celle d'une délégation
de pouvoirs pour un pouvoir très
centralisé sur la question de la gestion
de la crise sanitaire c'est bien contre
cela que nous nous sommes opposés hier
très bien merci max brisson va rentrer
dans le détail tout à l'heure avec un
sujet de clément méric sur le jeu dlr
parce que pas toujours claires mais moi
j'aimerais comprendre
à quarante députés aient l'air qui ont
voté contre au fond c'est ce qui a
permis à leur jette de ce pass vous vous
reconnaissez vous qu'êtes les
républicains dans l'attitude de vos
collègues députés quelle est la forme et
le fond que ça dans ce qui s'est passé
hier à l'assemblée d'abord le
gouvernement apprend qu'il n'y a qu'une
majorité relative tâter qu'il peut être
en minorité à l'assemblée ensuite il est
un fait découvrir avec sa majorité que
nous sommes une démocratie parlementaire
et que la loire entre un coût d'une
certaine manière elle sort différemment
c'est comme ça dans tous les pays
d'europe nous sommes une démocratie
parlementaire ainsi avait voulu le
général de gaulle en 1958 et puis le
gouvernement découvre qu'à une navette
et que le sénat ça compte cet après midi
lors des questions d'actualité le
gouvernement multiplier compris gérald
darmanin les signes d'infection
vis-à-vis du sénat et puis toujours sur
la forme qui a le langage guerrier de
madame bornes certes peut-être à 2
heures du matin il faut qu'elle
abandonne ce langage guerrier le vote
d'un amendement ce n'est pas la guerre
il faut arrêter il faut discuter avec le
parlement et arrêter de voir passer en
force le temps du passage en force il
jupiter c'est un mois ce que j'entends
dans tout ça c'est beaucoup la méthode
qui est mise en cause presque autant que
le fond voire plus à l'aise il sur le
faut pour terre qui concerne le sénat
tranquillement nous allons réécrire le
texte mais nous nourrir nous ne
rétablirons pas le texte du gouvernement
nous allons pour le sujet de mon
matériel est plutôt favorables aux
contrôles aux frontières mais dans
certains conditions et pas des
conditions qui étaient écrites par le
gouvernant toute façon nous aurions
modifier le texte et quand un coup de
colère de nos amis députés lr je te
comprends ses 12000 ces passants
infirmières comme une fois de plus avec
arrogance nous verrons a bien voulu le
dire c'est 12000 soignants qui sont
concernés ça mériterait d'écouter le
groupe l air il faudra dorénavant que la
majorité perd de sa superbe et se met à
écouter écouter c'est la base du bon
sens de la démocratie parlementaire ans
par jean philippe desrosiers et
bienvenue sur ce plateau c'est
passionnant de voir ce au parlement
naître sous nos yeux on est dans
l'inédit ce qui s'est passé hier soir au
fond va être amenée à se répéter ou on
est dans quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel dans l'attelage ddd voix
des différents groupes qui se sont
mélangés si j'avais une boule de cristal
qui permettent de répondre précisément à
votre question je la vendrai très très
cher autour de cette table à mon avis
je crois que effectivement on se rend
compte aussi on a raison de le dire que
il y a un parlement que l'on retrouve un
parlement et que le parlement retrouve
sa place qui a toujours été la sienne il
retrouve sa place pourquoi parce qu'il
se trouve désormais au parlement des
hommes et des femmes à même d'exercer
les compétences qui sont les leurs ce
que pendant trop longtemps on a oublié
et que c'est notamment ses députés à un
petit peu moins les sénateurs mais aussi
dans une certaine mesure avait oublié de
d'exercer la plénitude de leurs
compétences et de constater qu'ils sont
en mesure de bloquer des textes je crois
que ce qui s'est passé hier c'est
effectivement le terme de clarification
et est assez approprié
c'est à dire que il y à une illustration
que pour voir un texte aboutir
premièrement le gouvernement est
contraint de faire des concessions et
d'accepter que le texte qu'il a déposée
ne sera pas le texte qui sortira et
deuxièmement dans ses concessions qu'il
est tenu d'écouter les autres groupes et
d'accepter un certain nombre de leurs
propositions je n'ai toujours pas de
boule de cristal mais quelque chose me
dit que si le gouvernement était allé un
petit peu en direction des attentes des
uns ou des autres peut-être que cet
article 2 aurait pu soit être amendé en
faveur des attentes des uns ou des
autres ou si un autre article de 1 2a ou
2b ça l'avait terrassé l'agression la
négociation et du coup propulsion aurait
plus à la méthode on est bien parce
qu'on sent beaucoup que voilà c'est ça
qu'on vous reproche et on l'entend il ya
le fond mais il ya aussi la façon de
faire et olivier verront qu'il n'a pas
du tout goûté ce qui s'est passé dans
l'hémicycle et qui a répondu ceci et je
ne suis pas sûr que ça permette de
trouver l'apaisement écouter vu des
tweets de
député la france insoumise se félicitant
d'avoir empêché le rétablissement du
pass sanitaires dans les transports en
commun le texte qui l'ont rejetée ne
disait pas cela c'est uniquement des
mesures de protection aux frontières en
cas de menace sérieuse grave virale et
les uns et les autres s'applaudissant
debout dans un moment de fusion
fraternel tout sous le regard goguenard
des florian philippot et autres francis
lalanne marc ferracci la fusion
fraternelle pourquoi vous vous utilisez
cette cette stratégie là de dire au fond
sur un sujet très précis le passionné
terre aux frontières
l'heure est grave de voir se mêler le rn
la lr et la nuque une fusion fraternelle
c'est des mots forts ça veut dire deux
parties trois partis frères encore une
fois je pense que le regarde ça faisait
référence à la situation sanitaire
d'abord je veux dire et d'ailleurs pour
rebondir sur les propos qu'il avait
tenus que cet article 2 il a été amendée
il a d'ailleurs été amendé en acceptant
des amendements de l'opposition et de
l'opposition et l'air je pense que
monsieur brice on y sera sensible parce
que je sais que le sénat ait eu l'heur
sensible la prise en compte des points
de vue des collectivités territoriales
mais un amendement a été acceptée qui
moi me paraissait de bon sens consistant
à demander l'avis des exécutifs locaux
s'agissant évidemment de l'outre-mer et
de la corse pour mettre en place les
dispositions qui était prévu par
l'article donc il faut quand même
rétablir certains éléments de vérité il
ya eu du dialogue en amont de ce trio
différence c'est qu'au fond ça réveille
un peu clémente et max philippot lalanne
on voit bien ce que je sais pas si on en
est arrivé et je pense que il ya des
choses qui sont vertueuses qui se sont
passés en amont de ce texte en
particulier en commission je pense qu'il
faut qu'on continue collectivement et
bien à dialoguer dans ce cadre j'ai été
moi même sur un autre texte les deux
pays et le pouvoir d'achat ce matin en
commission des affaires sociales et les
échanges ont été tout à fait vertueux et
fertile mais pour revenir un autre nom
vous récusez le procès sur la météo j'ai
entendu hier dans l'hémicycle j'ai
entendu hier dans l'hémicycle des propos
à gauche comme à droite d'ailleurs que
je pensais avoir purement et simplement
disparu de notre débat public j'ai
entendu des gens qui remettait en
question l'efficacité des vaccins j'ai
entendu des gens par christina des
propos qui étaient simplement contraire
à ce que disait la science j'ai pas
identifié mais quand on entend le broie
style assez difficile d'identifier des
voix nominalement mai mais le fait est
que ça a effectivement fait émerger
des positions beaucoup ils sont qui sont
qui sont assez assez triste la question
fait savoir si c'est un problème ou pas
de démocratie parlementaire que sur un
amendement les voies deux parties qui se
combattent et biologiquement votent
ensemble ça vous met mal à l'aise vous
demandez vous voit au rassemblement
national parce que vous avez utilisé
l'argument au moment des élections
poste-clé 1 pour dénoncer l'attitude de
la mède jour d'abord je trouve qu'il ya
quand même une forme de toupet assez
inouï de la part de la majorité de nous
renvoyer l'idée qui aurait des accords
prétendu entre ces forces d'opposition
les députés les ministres en marche
renaissance pendant l'entre-deux tours
des élections législatives ont mis un
trait d'égalité entre la nuque et le
rassemblement national en refusant de
faire des choix alors même que nous
mêmes nous n'avions dit pas une voix au
rassemblement national que gérald
darmanin se vautre dans les pas des
propositions de marine le pen donc je
trouve que il faut cesser ce ces
procédés la deuxième chose c'est que je
rappelle qu'il ya cinq groupes
parlementaires hier qui ont voté contre
cet article 2 ou se sont abstenus et que
ce qui consisterait comme vous le faites
jusque là où comme olivier ferrand le
fait avec arrogance a essayé de nous
renvoyer en permanence aux marges de la
république par des procédés honteux ça
va pas marcher ça va pas marcher et je
crois que les citoyens de ce pays voit
combien nos propositions sont des
propositions portées dans le débat
public des revendications que même il
porte les tests gratuits
la situation de l'hôpital public les
purificateurs d'air dans les écoles en
quoi cela correspond à des thèses anti
vaccins en plus vous le dites à une
députée d'un groupe qui promeut la
vaccination donc si vous voulez si vous
continuez dans cette méthode ça veut
dire que ce moment de clarification et
de révélations dire allez vous rien
compris bon je vous propose marc créatif
vous donner oui mais je voudrais vous
montrez ce petit sujet et vous répondez
juste après parce qu'en fait il ya quand
même quelques états d'âme au sein de la
nuque qui montre que tu s'est passé hier
soir n'est pas à l'aise tout le monde
c'est un sujet de clément perreault et
je vous promets que vous répondez à tous
les projets 7 après
les députés est raide et france a
soumises debout pour applaudir à
l'unisson le rejet d'un article là c'est
les filets de l'intérieur par plusieurs
députés macro nist dont chris cate et
blue pour elle ces images sont la preuve
d'une connivence entre les deux extrêmes
je suis assise pour vous mettre un peu
en visuel bien au milieu de l'hémicycle
et donc j'ai vu littéralement aussi bien
l'extrême droite que l'extrême gauche se
tendre les mains se tendre les bras
tellement ils étaient contents de ce
qu'ils avaient réussi à faire
politiquement et je ne dis pas
sanitairement c'était un moment
extrêmement gênant perturbant je pense
que c'est une image qui va rester gravé
sa vidéo a dépassé le million de vues en
quelques heures côté est reine cet
épisode semble parfaitement assumé vous
est pas parce qu elle est fille va dire
que il fait beau je vais dire qu'il
pleut très clairement on a des
convergences sur certains points mais
aussi avec les républicains aussi
parfois avec l'arrivée au sein de la
nuque par contre ces applaudissements
conjoint provoque qu'a posteriori une
certaine gêne c'est pas une image a
donné dans un hémicycle surtout quand on
est sûr sur un voilà sur ce texte qui
aurait qui comporte que deux articles
sur lequel je pense qu'on aurait pu
s'entendre en amant en attendant qu'est
ce qu'on fait en reste assis et puis on
dit que c'est le rassemblement national
qui a gagné l'amendement leur comportait
aussi voyez c'est très compliqué après
jour sincèrement c'est pas de gaîté de
coeur qu'on entend matin midi et soir
que air est née votre moi parti
politique c'est même combat c'est un
abandon ce moment laisse augurer de
nouveaux débats très houleux dans
l'hémicycle eux dès la semaine prochaine
avec l'examen du projet de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat
marc ferati est ce que c'est vraiment la
bonne stratégie quand on voit votre
collègue appris ce qu'était venu au fond
dénoncé des alliances de circonstance rn
nuque ou témoin je vais très clair je
n'ai jamais dit et je n'ai jamais
entendu quiconque au sein de la majorité
présidentielle dire qu'il ya des accords
qui se noue donc ce que vous évoquez ça
n'est absolument pas notre état d'esprit
ça n'est pas ce que nous pensons ce
n'est pas ce que nous pensons ça nous
parce que je pense que ce serait parce
que nous pensons il faut le dire il ya
des convergences objectif quand on voit
que la même chose c'est une forme de
convergence on peut pas dire le
contraire il a été dit mais ça je pense
qu'il faut le dire il faut le dire très
clairement moi ce qu'il y aura des
convergences par exemple votre texte
avec
probablement mais je pense qu'il faut il
faut dire cela de manière de manière
très claire ensuite vous êtes allé sur
le fond d'autres propos précédents en
évoquant les tests gratuits en évoquant
l'hôpital en évoquant des sujets qui
sont au coeur des préoccupations des
français et nous le savons et nous le
savons moi je tiens quand même à
rappeler que ce texte n'avait pas
vocation à être un texte qui ressort
qu'ils réforment l'hôpital public ça
n'était pas sa finalité sa finalité
c'était de prendre en compte et bien la
fin du cadre juridique qui se profile au
31 juillet qui permettait de prendre ses
mesures d'urgence et donc ce texte avait
une finalité qui était limité dans son
objet est ce que ça signifie qu on
n'abordera pas les sujets que vous avez
évoqué les tests gratuits qu on
n'abordera pas les sujets du bien-être
des soignants des moyens de l'hôpital je
vous le dis qu'on va les aborder pour
une raison simple c'est que tous ces
sujets figure dans le programme du
président de la république et jusqu'à
présent pour avoir participé un peu au
quinquennat précédent la majorité
présidentielle fait tout ce qu'elle peut
pour mettre en oeuvre son programme vous
aurez évidemment des divergences de vues
dans la mise en oeuvre de ce programme
et on discutera de ces sujets là mais
dire que on a écarté d'un revers de la
main tous ces sujets a sur ce texte là
je trouve que ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
exactement siège de roisel une portée
limitée votre regard des coûts vie la
pratique des institutions le regard du
constitutionnaliste et je suis pas là
pour donner des leçons mais une analyse
effectivement un certain nombre de deux
de revendication de demandes de des
oppositions ne pouvait pas figurer dans
ce texte parce que ça aurait été
qualifié de cavalier législatif
c'est-à-dire que cette aide est pourvu
d'un lien avec l'objet d'une objets des
textes à une formule qui peut justement
permettre de faire avancer c'est que la
majorité sachant que c'est un cavalier
accepte de l'intégrer le texte est
déférée au conseil constitutionnel et
puis après c'est censuré par le conseil
constitutionnel
tout le monde est content ou presque
sauf ceux qui ont défendu l'amendement
de toute façon pour pouvoir avancer vers
l'enfer de la stratégie il va falloir
faire de la concertation et donc pour
dans la concertation puisque c'est dans
le programme puisque visiblement la
majorité plutôt ouvert sur ça pour faire
avancer le texte là je parle de toute
façon tout le fait objective je sais pas
s'il fallait intégrer l'article 2 ou pas
mais si l'objectif des 1 c'était doit
d'intégrer l'article de l'objectif des
autres c'est d'obtenir la gratuité des
tests la réintégration des soignants etc
bon eh bah effectivement on peut soit
trouvé une façon de s'arranger en
préparant un projet
en intégrant un amendement qui tu as qu
effectivement il soit censure il est
très clairement dit n'y aura pas au fond
de donnant-donnant c'est à dire on veut
bien discuter
sur le fond d'un article des conditions
de son application d'un amendement mais
pas je vote elle tel article dans tel
texte en échange d'autres choses sur un
autre texte ou sur un autre objet il a
très clairement dit y'a pas de deal
possible we go se verra n'était plus en
charge des relations avec le parlement
et d'ailleurs c'est une excellente chose
parce qu'il est le plus mal placé sa
méthode est ce un moyen de faire la
manière dont ils sur réagissent
j'ai entendu beaucoup de propos
l'inquiéter en sus réaction ça va mettre
et conduire le gouvernement dans une
impasse immédiatement dans ce contexte
là il faut pas surréagir
au contraire essayez d'écouter comme jeu
comme je disais tout à l'heure faut pas
arrêter il faut arrêter d'hystériser le
débat est actuellement le gouvernement
ils me permettent aux spécialistes du
sujet est en train d'hystériser le le
débat à vous qui veut que tout cela
échoue à moins que ce soit une stratégie
enfin il faudra le dire aux français moi
je pense qu'il faut abandonner l'eau
comme la cayrié comme son héros ne se
verront s'occupe doit être porte-parole
du gouvernement mais surtout nous qui ne
s'occupe pas des relations avec le
parlement et puis il faut qu'on
travaille sereinement et nous allons
travailler sereinement nous pensons en
effet qu'il faut se prémunir contre des
variants qui peut être demain plus
offensif il faut permettre au
gouvernement d'avoir les moyens de
réagir dans l'urgence l'idée de devoir
devoir fermer les frontières dans une
situation compliquée est quelque chose
que nous portons mais nous portons aussi
la question aujourd'hui d'émettre des
personnels soignants qui ont pu être
exclu pour des raisons qui leur
appartenait mettons qu'il faut quand
même prendre en compte la situation ce
thème rif au travail et
des provocations version verrons ça
c'est pour la méthode mais on a bien
compris que la balle est clairement dans
votre camp et également au sénat la
stratégie des républicains en question
on voit cela la clé numérique
elle est fille et le rn exulte pas
d'effusion en revanche sur les bancs des
républicains ils viennent pourtant de
voter eux aussi la suppression d'un
article clé du projet de loi sanitaire
leur message est clair le gouvernement
va devoir changer de méthode s'il veut
obtenir les voix des républicains
ce soir nous avons un constat de la
réalité des forces politiques présentes
dans l'hémicycle et de la réalité de la
méthode que nous devrons adopter à
l'avenir pour travailler les textes la
plus forte erreur de méthode c'est de
n'avoir pas pu travailler en amont de la
présentation de la discussion du texte à
l'assemblée nationale le fond des
propositions c'est au scénar que va se
jouer l'acte 2 de ce projet de loi est
là aussi c'est la droite qui détient la
clé alors quand elisabeth bornes en
appelle à la responsabilité de la
chambre haute bruno retailleau se crispe
un peu si elle veut compter sur le sénat
elle doit aussi recevoir par exemple les
présidents de groupes du sénat pour
l'instant et les a ignorés la a reçu les
présidents de groupe de l'assemblée
nationale moi j'ai toujours été
favorables aux contrôles aux frontières
vous accélérez
mais on aura des questions à poser
notamment sur la réintégration du
personnel soignant la droite sénatoriale
est donc d'accord avec le gouvernement
sur un dispositif que les députés aient
l'air viennent de supprimer difficile
d'y voir une cohérence politique mais la
manoeuvre permet à la droite de montrer
au gouvernement quel est désormais
incontournable dans la recherche de
majorités
max brisson vous comprenez que pour les
électeurs vos électeurs se soient pas
toujours très clair ce sont des gens qui
sont sensibles aux vaccins qui n'ont pas
contrôler pas sanitaire
ya une ligne marc l'ex pour voter contre
et henning retailleau pour voter pour
faucon aux électeurs et l'ensemble des
français
redécouvrent ce qu'est une démocratie
parlementaire le texte n'est pas encore
sorti du parlement ça va encore bouger
où nous avons le temps nous verrons bien
le texte sorti parlement il y avait deux
navettes il faut du temps les citoyens
regarde les votes à l'assemblée une
chaîne comme lcp je pense que vous avez
la volonté je demande d'expliquer
décortiqué nous sommes pas sûrs dont
deux sur le plateau d'une chaîne
d'information continue nous avons je
crois le temps de dire que la loi ça se
fabrique parlent échangent par la
discussion par l'aller-retour et par la
navette c'est comme ça qu'on fabrique de
bonnes lois c'est le modèle c'est le
contraire de lui tu livre de monsieur
bruno le maire il ya quelques mois
qu'ils voulaient aller vite on ne
fabrique pas la loi en allant vite il
faut prendre du temps alors il faut que
je vous dédie cela madame bond dans la
première ministre n'est pas là pour dire
ce qui est responsable ou non dans le
vote du sénat je suis je regrette ce
sont les sénateurs qui diront ce qui
leur paraît responsables dans leurs
rangs et se tourne à des revues des
réactions mauvaises manières elles
étaient prêtes au sénat après mon
collègue député de 10 est fortement si
début du dialogue en amont n'en serions
peut-être pas là il faut que le
gouvernement apprennent à dialoguer en
amont à échanger à discuter pour faire
avancer des textes à propositions entre
les députés sénateurs nous verrons bien
c'est un discours que j'entends beaucoup
nous allons nous retrouver dans une
ville que j'aime bière à biarritz ou
mois de septembre pour apprendre
davantage à travailler ensemble au coton
de journée par le terrain nous allons
faire ensemble il y avait très longtemps
que députés sénateurs aient l'air
n'avait pas fait leur journée
parlementaire ensemble et nous allons
chercher une méthode dans l'intérêt
général du pays nous sommes dans
l'opposition on a tellement voulu en
avoir embarqué certains de nos amis
faire du débauchage ça n'a pas marché
nous sommes dans l'opposition mais avec
le souci que nos électeurs se rassure
que les français soient sûr toujours de
l'intérêt général la loi fillon dans son
discours être associés en amont ils
devront rendre le temps de l'écouter un
texte en qu'il n'ait pas voté en fin de
parcours n'est pas définitif ça devrait
réjouir résonner chez chaque
parlementaire l'idée que le parlement
prend le temps le parlement est un lieu
d'écouté et des changes et qu' il n'est
pas juste la chambre d'enregistrement du
président de la république et des
volontés du président de la république
donc je me retrouve n'ont pas forcément
dans les propositions que nous porterons
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi comme
dans d'autres mais bien dans l'idée que
voilà il va falloir compter sur un
parlement fort et que je crois que c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle vous savez
encore
la 6ème république mais si on peut
mettre un peu de 6e dans la cinquième on
va peut réellement de la famar karachi
mais un petit mode
retrouver effectivement avec un
parlement fort ne pas oublier le
parlement est fort et que le parlement
est composé de deux assemblées de deux
chambres l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat et là aussi il ya peut-être une
erreur
politique stratégique de la part du
gouvernement qui a envoyé tous ces
textes d'abord à l'assemblée nationale
conclusion d'ailleurs un embouteillage
on l'a vu hier avec des députés qui
étaient à la faune séance et en
commission des finances bon si je
l'avais envoyé le projet de loi sécurité
sanitaire d'abord au sénat pour laisser
la loi de règlement ça c'est obligatoire
par la constitution d'abord à
l'assemblée nationale le sénat aurait
été mis sur le devant de la scène où il
y aurait eu des égards vis-à-vis du
sénat et je pense que le débat
effectivement aurait pu être ainsi un
petit peu plus apaisé pas mieux faire
c'est ce qu'on vous dit au fond dans la
majorité macro nice vous pouvez mieux
faire il faut écouter écoutez moi je
souscris à ce qui a été dit par par
mathieu brisson pas ce qui vient d'être
dit je pense que on le dit depuis des
semaines il faut qu'on change de méthode
ça va concerner gouvernement parce que
co construire en amont ça veut dire
discuter sur le fond à la fois avec les
députés sénateurs de la majorité mais
aussi avec les députés et sénateurs de
l'opposition sur des objets politiques
ça va signifier envoyer les textes ou
présenter les textes en allemand il en
amont et puis dans un séquençage qui
permet un examen serein des textes parce
que c'est vrai que koné fait que révéler
qu
effectivement c'est l'examen en
parallèle de deux textes que son pays et
le pouvoir d'achat lpg le sanitaire
entre la commission à la séance
évidemment ça n'est pas très confortable
et dernier point il va falloir également
que le volume des textes se réduisent
afin de permettre un examen serein et
puis construire des choses qu'ils soient
qui soit profitable à tout le monde dans
les semaines qui viennent enfin un
retrait dans les jours qui viennent sur
ce cas vous êtes un travail merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir participé à ce
débat sur lcp on va prendre un peu de
hauteur à présent et même remonter loin
très loin dans le temps le télescope
spatial james webb le plus puissante
observatoire astronomique jamais lancé
dans l'espace nous a offert hier des
images exceptionnelles d'une grande
beauté elles ont fait le tour du monde
et elles nous montrent l'univers tel
qu'il était juste après le big bang
c'est à dire à 13 milliards
d'années-lumière alors pour les
comprendre on va accueillir un physicien
philosophe des sciences et grand
vulgarisateur un peu poète aussi etienne
klein nous rejoint juste après ce sujet
de marco polo
si on vous invite etienne klein c'est
parce que l'univers ne cesse de nous
émerveiller ce soir votre mission si
vous l'acceptez c'est de partager vos
connaissances sur les découvertes de ces
dernières semaines exceptionnelles nous
a tout dit mais pour tout vous dire on
n'y comprend pas grand chose on n'est
pas moins bon citoyen si on est
indifférent à la science on a le droit
de ne pas du tout s'y intéresser mais
c'est bien les met en contact avec elle
au moins une fois pour voir si on a du
coup pour elle etienne klein vous êtes
une tête bien faite physicien philosophe
des sciences vous dirigez un laboratoire
de recherche sur les sciences de la
matière pour new media vous êtes surtout
un incontournable vulgarisateur
scientifique vos livres sont des trésors
de savoir accessible à tous c'est un peu
la science pour les nuls car pour vous
tout s'explique je pense que tout est
bleu diaries abl à condition qu'on ait
beaucoup de temps en a rarement du temps
et par exemple la physx écrit pour ce
qui est des formats limaille des
équations mathématiques et dire avec des
mots ce que dirait une équation si elle
pouvait parler ça prendrait beaucoup de
temps ce soir nous allons plonger avec
vous dans l'espace temps avec d'abord
ces photos sublimes à peine croyable
réalisé par james webb le plus grand
télescope spatial jamais construit à 11
milliards de dollars
sur ce cliché des points lumineux des
milliers de galaxies vieille de 13
milliards d'années remontant au big bang
sous nos yeux c'est l'origine de
l'univers qui se dévoile peu à peu c'est
très difficile d'imaginer que avant
y'avait pas ce studio est pas la terre
est rien et qu'est ce qui a fait qu'est
née la première étoile de l'univers la
première aube de l'univers la première
galaxy on va être les témoins de la
première lumière de toute l'histoire de
l'univers et l'autre chose qui est
l'autre objectif l'autre pilier c'est
qu'on essaie de voir si on peut
découvrir la signature de possibles vie
sur d'autres planètes et les découvertes
ne s'arrête pas ici en mai dernier à 27
mille années lumière de nous un réseau
de télescopes publie cette image un trou
noir supermassif
en plein coeur de notre galaxie la voie
lactée des découvertes vertigineuse
alors etienne klein dit nous en quoi ces
télescopes ses outils technologiques
révolutionne l'astronomie à vous la
parole
bonsoir etienne klein je suis ravi de
vous accueillir sur ce plateau alors
avant de revoir les images ensemble et
de répondre à marco pommier je voudrais
savoir qu'est ce qu'on ressent comme
émotion quand on est un grand
scientifique comme vous une excitation
on imagine puissante quand on découvre
ces images c'est chaque fois la même
chose en fait et d'ailleurs depuis
quelques années on fait des découvertes
importantes il le boson de higgs une
particule élémentaire qui a été détecté
pour la première fois il ya exactement
dix ans au cern c'est pas
l'astrophysique c'est de la physique des
particules on avait une particule qui
était prédite par les théoriciens depuis
48 ans et on a vu sa trace dans des
détecteurs c'est quand même une émotion
assez forte on touche le vide quantique
et puis ensuite les ondes
gravitationnelles qui avait été pris
l'appareil stein en 1916 qu'on a pu
détecter grâce à des grands instruments
un siècle plus tard en 2016 et puis le
trou noir supermassif wagner et si au
mois de mai puis là des images
incroyables
mode révolution
instruments on ouvre une sorte de
nouvelles fenêtres on peut découvrir de
belles choses en l'occurrence ce
télescope spatial qui situait très
malade la terre il a un million cinq
cent mille kilomètres il a voyagé à très
longtemps brd arrivé à ce point de
lagrange qu'on l'appelle il observe avec
de la lumière infrarouge en l'univers
est en expansion donc les objets
s'éloigne de nous et leur fréquence la
fréquence des lumières que ces objets
nous envoie se décale vers le rouge donc
si on veut les voir il faut aller les
chercher dans l'infrarouge et c'était
les scop voit dans l'infrarouge avec une
résolution spatiale très très grande il
pourrait voir un ballon de football à
500 km donc ça permet de voir des objets
très loin donc temps des phases où ils
sont très jeunes où il était il ya très
longtemps dans l'histoire ou bien des
objets plus proche mais peu lumineux
alors on va les regarder ensemble à
nouveau ces images on va commencer par
ce paysage de montagnes et de vallées
parsemé des toiles qu'on appelle la
nébuleuse de la carène qu'est ce qu'on
voit précisément sur ces images barre je
ne vois pas alors là non la voix ce que
vous la voyez pas les petits écrans là
on la connaissait depuis longtemps cette
cette nébuleuse
on allait des photos plus récentes
prises par le télescope d'avant qui
s'appelait automne bbl mais la
résolution bien meilleur on voit des
détails on voit des jeunes étoiles on
voit que c'est comme si on était passé
d'une phase impressionniste à une phase
réaliste on voit les petits détails
l'image est très belle et émouvante on
l'a dit mais les astrophysiciens il vous
regardez aussi tout ce qui est contenue
comme information dans tous les petits
petit pixel les fréquences qui sont la
signature d'éléments chimiques qui sont
présents ils vont donc pouvoir en
apprendre davantage sur la façon dont
cette nébuleuse est constituée comment
elle évolue mais parée des couleurs pour
moi elles sont quasi psychédélique ses
couleurs c'est la farouche qui ai fait
ça il faut se couleurs avec lesquels
elles sont des phares mais voilà le sont
déformés mais on peut quand même s'il
s'est un peu pour séduire mais oui il
fallait que ce soit spectaculaire aussi
c'est un outil qui
alors j'aimerais vous entendre sur le
quintette de stéphane comment on dit ça
de stéphan brousse était forte ces
regroupements galaxies en collision
en fait c 5 galaxy se dit qu'ils coupent
qui vont aussi juste rappel un groupe
visuel si on les voit ensemble en fait y
en a quatre qui sont en interaction les
unes avec les autres dansent ensemble il
ya une autre qui au premier plan et donc
qu'elle fait pas partie du groupe c'est
plutôt un gpo grand on appelait ça c'est
pas un quintet ces quatre galaxies qui
dansent ensemble et qui interagissent en
échangeant des gaz de la matière et ça
c'est quelque chose qui va être vu par
plusieurs des instruments de james webb
télescope et les astrophysiciens
attendent beaucoup de ce qu'ils vont
apprendre grâce à cela la nébuleuse
planétaire de l'anneau australe alors ça
c'est une partie de ce regroupement on
vient de voir deux galaxies c'est pas
une planète c'est quoi des bulles de gaz
et de poussières ce jeu soufflée par une
étoile en fin de vie étoile qui a
explosé et c'est le gaz qu'elle a
dispersé dans l'espace qu'on voit
sur des distances qui sont beaucoup plus
grande qu'elle est donc ça t'apprendra
j'imagine les choses sur la façon dont
les étoiles meurt ce qu'on voit là sur
ces images c'est le passé ultras l'ont
atteint en mode cloud post rock est un
spécialiste du temple dans le futur on
voit que le passé mais est-ce que ça
fait forcément dire qu'à l'instant t où
on voit ces images cette réalité
n'existe plus la voilà dans notre
présent n'existe plus au moment où vont
les voir en fait c'est bien du fait que
c'est la lumière qui nous et on voyait
la lumière infrarouge c'est la lumière
elle se propage à la vitesse de la
lumière qui est très grande mais pas
infini de sorte qu'elle met du temps à
nous arriver et plus allé loin play le
mettant donc quand on reçoit l'image eh
bien il ya un effet de décalage temporel
qui fait que plus on regarde de loin
plus un mais deux tons pour devenir et
plus on voit les vrais dans la phase où
visiter jeunes et la première image qui
était montré du james webb
ça montre des galaxies en formation et
des étoiles qui se forme car on va la
voir cette image aussi c'est la masse
max et sa lettre c'est la première qui a
été qui a été montré ça c'est une photo
qui montre les avis qu'ils étaient il ya
très
bien on voit des effets de lentille
gravitationnelle il ya des galaxies qui
ont des formes un peu courbé comme ça
s'il y avait du fait qu'entre
cette profondeur du ciel et nous il ya
une galaxie qui fait office de lentille
gravitationnelle est donc ça déforme les
rayons lumineux il ya plusieurs images
du même objet qui se se font voir c'est
la profondeur du temps raison une fois
de plus est-ce qu'il y en a qui sont
plus importantes que d'autres danses
contes un devoir je suis pas capable de
vous dire je pense qu'elle passionne
tout les astrophysiciens il ya plusieurs
équipes qui se partagent le temps
d'observer analyses ont duré des années
les observations ont duré dix à dix
années à peu près et de toute façon
c'est que le cycle des bulles assez
nouvelle histoire qui commence ryan ou
la main nouvel instrument un peu comme
galilée a pointé sa lunette on a un
nouvel instrument voilier nouvelles
choses et ça change en général
la façon dont on voit l'univers il se
pourrait que le ciel ne se ressemble
plus alors justement on en profite on
continue à faire de la pédagogie vous en
parliez tout à l'heure des photos ou des
images grâce à des révolutions
scientifiques technologiques sont
nombreuses dans l'histoire récente vous
avez cité cette photo du trou noir alors
il ya deux il ya deux photos 10 novembre
10 avril 2019 et une du 12 mai on va
l'avoir réussi 12 mai 2022 monstre
gravitationnelle qui déforme alors ça
c'est complètement vertigineux à la fois
l'espace mais aussi le temps c'est pas
les photos c'est quoi la passe 4 mars à
n'avait pas de lumière c'est un objet tu
quittais shum l'espace tellement
violemment dans son voisinage que déclin
de faisceaux de lumière paris revient
donc l'observateur qui est loin de voix
rien donc le trou noir ne peut pas se
être fait être par contre un stand à la
matière qui tourne autour avant d'être
absorbé qu'elle tombe très vite parce
que la vitesse de la lumière et c'est
cette matière qui émet de la lumière
qu'on capte et à partir d'elle on
reconstitue l'image d'un trou noir le
premier 2019 c'est le trou noir qui dans
une galaxie qui s'appelle m 87 qui est
très loin d'un énorme trou noir
plusieurs milliards de masse solaire et
voilà c'est beaucoup d'analystes de
données mais la deuxième image celle du
mois de mai 2022 montre le trou noir
supermassif qui est dans notre galaxie
et moi je pensais pas qu'on pourrait
voir ça parce qu'entre lui et nous il ya
vingt-six mille années lumière
et donc sur la trajectoire de ses rayons
lumineux et bien il ya plein de choses
des gaz des poussières qui perturbe
cette lumière il faut donc faire un
travail de nettoyage de la lumière émise
par la matière qui tourne autour de 3
qui est un travail d analyse colossal je
crois savoir du concours de beauté
beaucoup d'algorithmes beaucoup de temps
de travail beaucoup de voulais vous
poser une dernière question etienne
klein alors
on a fait face à une crise énergétique
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur au
cea au centre d'al aïd atomique de
l'énergie atomique on parle d'un projet
d'envergure hyper hyper attendu le
projet iter sur la fusion nucléaire et
non pas la fission parce qu'on sait
faire aujourd'hui qui pourrait peut-être
à terme vous allez nous dire quand il y
en a un en chine y en a en france au
fond nous approvisionner en énergie
comme on veut grâce au soleil c'est un
projet très propre énergie sans
exceptions l'énergie du soleil je vais
pas entrer trop dans les détails mais
dans le soleil il ya de l'hydrogène des
protons mais ils peuvent pas fusionner
parce qu'ils sont une charge électrique
qui fait qu'ils se repoussent et ils ne
peuvent pas se fondre en un seul noyau
mais temps en temps il dit tout bizarre
qui se passe un des proton devient le
tronc donc il vient notre put charge
électrique grâce à un processus qui
appelle l'interaction faible et une fois
que cette transformation a eu lieu alors
la fusion on peut se produire mais c'est
lent et c'est pour ça que le soleil mais
des milliards d'années a brûlé son
hydrogène et la puissance unité de
volume par mètre cube dans le soleil est
pas terrible 800 watts c'est moins que
le corps humain donc nous on veut pas du
tout faire la même chose que le soleil
on veut prendre des isotopes de
l'hydrogène les loyers de terriens bout
de tritium et ils vont pouvoir fusionner
par interaction forte ça libérera
neutrons qui a tapé les parois et qui va
déposer son énergie qui va te permet de
chauffer de l'eau et de faire du courant
électrique penser qu'on aura cinq ans
près de rentrer à cette énergie sans
polluer la planète la fusion c'est en
connaît par contre là il faut la
maîtriser et il faut avoir un plasma
parce que c'est trop température 100
millions de degrés et qu'ils soient
stabilisés dans glee terre premier
plasma 2025 et premier plasma de
deutérium tritium pour 2035 donc c'est
expérimental
oui c'est pas la joie non pour les
toutes prochaines décennies mais à terme
peut-être que ça serait une énergie
abondante parce que le deutérium y en a
beaucoup et puis ya peu de déchets
nucléaires et puis c'est globalement
beaucoup plus sûres non mais écoutez
merci elle souhaite merci beaucoup j'ai
tout compris j'espère que je n'aurai
déclic cette annonce était très clair
merci beaucoup vous pouvez rester avec
moi d'ailleurs si vous le souhaitez
c'est lors d'un d'accueillir nos a
franchi pour leur parti pris ce soir
alors va accueillir
brandon ouaret pour ses archives ses
archives ce soir sur les grandes
interviews du 14 juillet à la veille de
l'interview d'emmanuel macro la
sémiologue mariette darrigrand qui va
nous plonger ce soit dans l'univers d'un
mot qu'elle a choisi dans l'actualité
c'est le mot parler bien sûr et puis
l'international avec isabelle lasserre
isabelle qui revient sur ses
recrutements par la milice russe wagner
au sein des prisons dans un franchisé
voici bonsoir à vous et bienvenu alors
on commence avec vous brandon on est à
la veille de cette interview attendu le
14 juillet il a décidé mais ne
manqueront de renouer avec avec
l'exercice alors le chef de l'état donc
or nous en fait avec une très ancienne
tradition
une tradition instaurée pour la première
fois en 1976 par valéry giscard
d'estaing le jeune président moderne
inaugure l'exercice en direct des
jardins de l'elysée et vous allez voir
au micro d'yves mourousi le chef de
l'état ne perd pas de temps pour
s'attaquer aux sujets brûlants qui fait
l'actualité il y avait des roses mais
c'est un sol qui n'était pas très
favorable et c'est pourquoi on l'a
remplacé par un parterre français et qui
est entretenue par des jardiniers de la
ville de paris et nous avons comme vous
le voyez des fleurs qui ont résisté à la
sécheresse bien qu'elle ne soit pas
rosée
le sujet de tout l'entretien mais valéry
giscard d'estaing et décontractée se
croyait déjà en vacances à brégançon en
train de faire bronzette donc désormais
c'est devenu un peu un passage obligé et
avec ce rituel certaines déclarations
sont restés dans les annales mais pas
toujours dans le bon sens myriam
souvenez-vous de 1993 alors que le taux
de chômage en france atteint pour la
première fois les 10 % de la population
active les mots du président françois
mitterrand vous faire couler beaucoup
d'encre regardez ce qu'il disait dans la
lutte contre le chômage on a tout essayé
depuis maintenant 12 ans que j'occupe
ses fonctions tout a été essayé quelques
mois plus tard le président revient sur
ses propos polémiques qui selon lui ont
mal été interprétée tout va et c'est
vrai que c'est souvent l'occasion comme
ça en fin de saison avant de partir en
vacances de répondre un certain nombre
de polémiques pour les présidents il ya
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle de 2002 jacques chirac
est interrogé sur le financement de ces
voyages privés qu'il aurait effectué
avec l'argent du contribuable
alors qu'il était maire de paris entre
1992 et 1995
et comme défense le chef de l'état joue
la carte de l'ironie avec une onomatopée
devenu célèbre on voulait les sommes se
dé bon j'ai pas qu'elle se dégage c'est
que elles font pschitt pas si vous me
permettez cette expression par
définition on s'en lasse pas alors trois
ans plus tard le président réélu
récidive si l'on peut dire c'est le des
rangs le dernier rendez vous médiatiques
du président de la république avant les
vacances d'été alors forcément on se
lâche un peu plus que d'habitude en 2004
jacques chirac est interrogé sur son
ministre des finances un certain nicolas
sarkozy qui a des intentions
présidentielles de moins en moins
cachées alors jacques chirac on profite
pour lui rappeler que c'est lui le
patron et personne d'autre y a pas de
différend entre le ministre des finances
et moi pour une raison simple c'est que
notamment s'agissant de la dépense je
décide et il exécute alors que tous les
présidents ont discuté jusque là très
efficace tous les présidents s'étaient
jusque là prêté à l'exercice nicolas
sarkozy lui renoncera aux traditionnels
entretiens télévisés et françois
hollande lui au contraire décide d'y
revenir et oui comme un air de déjà vu
c'est en 2016 françois hollande en
profita à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle pour faire une mise au
point il recadre son ambitieux ministre
de l'économie vous voyez de qui je parle
c'est emmanuel macron ce ministre vient
tout juste de lancer ce mouvement en
marche
des règles dans un gouvernement de
cohérence la première c'est la
solidarité
c'est l'esprit d'équipé c'est de
défendre le bilan c'est d'être à plein
temps dans sa tâche et donc c'est une
règle qu'il doit respecter puis on a une
deuxième dans un gouvernement il n'y a
pas de démarche personnelle caen -
présidentielle jamais un président
n'aura pas freiner l'ascension du jeune
emmanuel macron qui va peut-être à son
tour demain nous proposer des petites
surprises merci beaucoup brandon
mariette
le mot de la semaine puisqu'on assiste à
la naissance d'un nouveau parlement
s'est parlé oui c'est un mot tout simple
évidemment mais j'ai trouvé face tous
intéressant d'y revenir parce que
lisabeth borgne a eu cette formule lors
de son discours de politique générale on
n'est pas là pour se compter mais pour
parler alors c'est passé un peu vite
parce qu'elle avait cette question de la
confiance va de confiance qu'elle ne
m'ennuie pas mais en réalité elle a
donné la définition même de ce qu'est un
parlement donc je trouvais ça fort de
dire venir parce que parler en fait
c'était une dimension sacrée dans notre
culture c'est étymologiquement c'est la
parabole la parabole christique est une
un mot qui vient de l'hébreu donc
c'était tout à fait intense dans notre
socle culturel et ça veut dire aussi que
l'on on parle avec de l'incarnation
parle avec des petits récits la parabole
des talents on comprend que son talent
on peut l'enterrer où on peut le
dilapider hop on a tout de suite compris
de quoi il s'agissait ce qu'il fallait
en faire on fait pas une grande leçon de
morale alors maintenant on est très
laïque on n'est pas dans cette pédagogie
un peu peut-être naïve mais je crois
qu'on a gardé cette solennité cette
importance de la parole fait l'actualité
du jour montre bien quand même hein
quand on s'engage dans la parole bat
normalement donne sa parole et ses
quelque chose peut-être qu'il y a
quelque part là loi dieu ou les le
peuple ou les concitoyens et c'est
précisément d'ailleurs ce sens assez
solennel et profond qui crée t mo
logiquement le mot parlement parlement
c'est là où l'on parlemente où l'on
parle alors la notion est antérieure la
démocratie on avait ça au moyen-âge donc
c'est dans cette vision chevaleresque
ont pour effet aux dames on veut quand
on donne sa parole et bien c'est quelque
chose de très important alors il y aura
dans notre actualité de l'assemblée
nationale prochainement probablement des
victimes il y aura ce qu'on a vu à la
chambre des lords parce que le mot est
passé en anglais en france il nous
lenglen où l'empreinte de
parlementarisme et on a vu dernièrement
ce qui se passait il ya des mots
d'oiseaux aussi un quand wayne injures
les stickers c'est un autre une autre
notion qui est justement moins belle on
pourrait dire que le la parole parce que
ça fait penser à timo logiquement c'est
quelque chose qu'on h manu que si vous
voulez quelqu'un que l'on que l'on
éparpillant quelque sorte alors que la
parole au contraire à quelque chose
d'élever alors bon on va voir il va sans
dire qu'on peut arriver se retrouvaient
ce climat qui nous élève à travers tu as
et la parole le verbe parler le verbe
devrait nous y inciter le mot parler
devrait nous y inciter l'actualité on
verra parce que la victime sera là le
silence sera là aussi on peut parler par
son silence non je crois que ce que
elisabeth bornes espère et c'est souvent
l'espoir des politiques c'est la
dimension performative cette parole
c'est à dire quand on dit quelque chose
et puis que ça agit quand vous dites oui
le jour où vous vous mariez c'est pas un
petit pleurait c'est transparent
voilà mais alors justement si on regarde
la métaphore du mariage on verra bien le
meilleur ou le pire tracé croyez ce
nouveau parlement qui trouverait une
forme de voile à de consensus de
compromis j'attends de voir mais
j'espère du progrès
je comprends et le bel on enchaîne avec
vous alors vous nous parler ce soir de
cette société de mercenaires on en a
beaucoup parlé ici depuis depuis
l'invasion russe et les prisons russes
sont sollicités les soldats pour trouver
des soldats wagner recrue des détenus
écoutez oui ça commence en tout cas
c'est une information qui vient à la
fois des services de renseignement
britanniques des ukrainiens
et puis des rares journalistes
indépendants qui résiste encore en
russie alors la liberté contre un
engagement de six mois dans le donbass
est ce que propose donc wagner la
société privée qui est dirigé par un
proche de vladimir poutine alors cette
armée de du kremlin c'est comme ça qu'on
la surnomme aurait déjà commencé à
recruter dans la prison de boucau vaut à
saint pétersbourg regarder sur les
images on voit on les voit vous les
voyez vous la et nourrir le récepteur
regarder les ailes sont assez originales
alors en plus d'une remise ou d'une
annulation de leur peine les volontaires
sont payés ils ne sont pas sûrs de
revenir du front bien sûr et s'ils sont
tués au combat leurs corps ne sera pas
ramené à la famille mais cette dernière
douchera une prime à ses conséquences
alors officiellement bien entendu la
mission consiste à détecter les fameux
nazis ukrainien du moins ce que vladimir
poutine considère comme les nazis
régnant et peu importe dans cette
histoire que les sympathisants du
troisième reich soit bien plus nombreux
chez les combattants de wagner qui sont
des années des tatouages nazis que parmi
les militaires craignent un parce que là
n'est pas la question alors dites-nous
pourquoi le kremlin ont fait appel à des
prisonniers il manque à ce point de
troupes il manque d'hommes et le
recrutement au bout de quatre mois et
demi de guerre est devenue une priorité
selon les ukrainiens mais aussi
certaines sources occidentales trente
cinq mille militaires russes auraient
été tuées depuis le début de la guerre
c'est beaucoup désormais tout le monde a
compris la guerre va être longue elle va
durer et pour l'instant vladimir poutine
a choisi de ne pas décréter la
mobilisation générale il a un mauvais
souvenir des guerres de tchétchénie qui
avait fait émerger les mères de soldats
qui avaient protesté contre la guerre et
contre le fait d'envoyer leurs fils et
cela avait fait perdre un certain nombre
de points de popularité à vladimir
poutine c'est la raison pour laquelle
depuis le 24 février les seuils de faire
la guerre en évitant que ces effets
négatifs atteignent les grandes villes
et recrutent des combattants dans des
régions très très éloigné de moscou est
très très éloigné aussi d'ukraine alors
avec les prisonniers de droit commun qui
sont de la chair à canon à la fois
discrète et bon marché
c'est encore mieux qui ira manifester en
effet en leur faveur quand ils seront
morts elle peut changer la donne cette
fête réserve de prisonniers des soldats
ce n'est pas garanti selon les selon les
trous selon les sources occidentales dix
à vingt mille combattants de wagner dont
certains d'ailleurs ont été rapatriés de
deux scieries recruter de série 1
combattent aux côtés des forces russes
depuis le début de la guerre et si son
souvenir est devenu visiblement un
soutien comme très important de l'armée
russe ils n'ont pas encore permis
d'arracher la victoire par contre le
recrutement des prisonniers de droit
commun au sein de wagner risque de
renforcer la culture criminelle
2 de la guerre russes et de l'entreprise
wagner on sait elle est réinstallé en
république centrafricaine comment mali
d'ailleurs elle s'est illustrée
absolument partout par des atrocités et
des crimes de guerre commises par tous
contre les populations civiles on verra
quel effet cela aura ou pas sur le
terrain ukrainien merci bonjour permis
n'avait qu'une une chronique un peu un
peu sombre le temps de vous dire merci
merci beaucoup etienne klein d'être
passé par le plateau de lcp c'était la
dernière de ça vous regarde de la saison
qui part en vacances toute l'équipe de
ça vous regarde revient évidemment à la
rentrée tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire j'en profite évidemment
pour remercier la régie la rédaction et
puis mon équipe jean-pierre montanay
notre rédacteur en chef préféré adrien
de volontat grand merci est il à partir
pour de nouvelles aventures que je lui
souhaite passionnante et puis bien sûr
et l'honneur picot et nos stagiaires
camille et chloé profitez bien de votre
été ne vous restait fidèle à lcp tout de
suite c'est un documentaire sur la secte
du temple solaire décidément dans le
vercors belle soirée et a très vite
[Musique]